c'est pas vrai quoique bon c'est pas
gagné c'est pas un coffre de débutants
aux non t'es sérieux c'est un carbone
d'elle un modèle de 1910 c'est avec le
même assise qu'ils ont fait de titanic
voir et tu peux faire quelque chose il
ya peut-être un moyen il n'aime pas trop
les grands froids au pérou l'iceberg
ah ouais ça a tué dicaprio ils sont tous
morts n'ont pas tous il restait encore
la vieille cabane on sait le caillou
dans l'océan
qu'est ce que tu fais j'ai fait couler
de l'eau dans le mécanisme
et puis j'ai injecté de l'azoté en jeu
l'an l'eau augmente de volume pas
d'acier et maintenant on attend chouette
y'a quoi tu caches des bijoux à part une
sorte de combinaison quoi
l'espèce de te fier trop tard pas
d'argent pas de bijoux que dalle non on
s'est planté je suis vraiment désolé
pour toi c'est que tu comptais sur ce
fric